and for the first time we are seeing
exactly
just how crowded our local hospitals are
federal data says that five valley
hospitals were at
capacity just last week the i-team's
david charns is in our newsroom tonight
and he's here with some of those new
numbers for us david
denise this data is for the week between
christmas and new year's it shows
five of our local hospitals here in the
valley were at or
above their icu capacity with covett of
course playing a big role here
overall icu's here in southern nevada
nearly 80 percent full right now with
about half filled with patients battling
kovid
members of the state's kova 19 task
force say there are no
immediate plans to expand any hospital
beds on an emergency basis here in our
area now this chart here
i want to show it to you because it is
from the nevada hospital association and
it shows our trend
for the number of people in the hospital
you see in all those lines there it
doesn't really matter which one you look
at but there's
a slight dip and then there's what we
saw last week
the dip there and then it sort of varies
a bit sort of stays
at the same level for a couple of weeks
all hospitals are required to report
how many people are in their icus to the
federal government
spring valley summerlin sunrise north
vista
and henderson all at or above icu
capacity from last week it does mean
that there are more people for the
number of beds they have but clearly
they are able to treat all those people
the state's coveted task force and local
hospital leaders
stressing they are and will be able to
handle a surge
as denise just mentioned if need be now
these icu numbers are also
total capacity we're not just talking
covet patients of course people are sick
for other reasons
those covet patients making up about
half of beds filled on
average we also want to emphasize that
busy hospitals aren't a reason for
staying away from the hospital of course
an emergency please go there
these figures we're bringing you here
are from the university of minnesota
kova 19 hospitalization
tracking project and data reported to
the government
the nevada hospital association does not
release these specific
hospital data like we just showed you
but it hasn't told us why
live in the newsroom tonight i'm david
charns 8 news now